Virginia governor Glenn young can
pardoning this Dad Scott Smith who was
arrested for disorderly conduct during
his local school board meeting after his
daughter was sexually assaulted by a
transgender biological male student in a
school bathroom
well that pardon's not sitting well with
the George Soros back prosecutor who
brought the charges she still wants to
go after the father after lashing out at
Junkin and accusing him of doing it for
political gain but the dad is hitting
back
she is one of the most evil people I've
ever met you know unfortunately I had to
deal with her face to face with the
prosecution of the sexual predator of my
daughter we need to vote her out you
know if you live in a somehow Buddha
biburai has not made news headlines you
know everybody's talking about the big
city soils process funded prosecutors
somehow Buddha's flown under the radar
she is partially funded by yeah well let
me tell you she's one of the worst
all right so judge explain this to me
this guy was extremely angry for his
daughter being raped in the school
covering it up they arrest him prosecute
him he gets pardoned and the Soros die
still wants to put him in prison yeah
she wants to put him in prison for
disorderly conduct look I think the
timing is really important here on May
28th his daughter was assaulted by
someone who identified as a female that
they put a skirt on went into the girl's
bathroom and raped his daughter so
that's May 28th folks she reports it
immediately and on June 22nd the guy is
still not arrested all right he then
goes and says to the school board my
daughter was raped and she reported it
they all said that's a lie no one
reported it and now the superintendent
of schools he is now facing a charge of
lying or uh for saying that that they
never received any information about the
the rape I mean they're just liars and
what they don't want is they don't want
to be in a situation where they have to
punish anyone so they send the uh
transgender guide to another school
where he molests another girl all right
father is furious the guy's not even
arrested for the rape of his daughter
they're lying and saying that they never
reported the case they arrest him and
charge him with obstruction resisting
arrest that's overthrown and now she
wants them for discon disorderly conduct
is baloney okay it's like he's acting
out in a public place and it might be
dangerous yeah he's acting out because
he's saying my daughter reported a rape
and you're not doing anything let me
tell you how bad these people are they
are actually looking to stop uh
reporting crimes to the police in their
jurisdiction they don't even want to
tell the cops about crimes occurring in
their jurisdiction and she's a Soros
prosecutor she doesn't know what the
heck she's doing she's an ideologue and
that's the end of it now let me just
tell you one thing Junkin when he went
on television
he was really classy he never mentioned
the transgender thing he just talked
about rape he talked about the schools
schools being in a position to protect
children and parents being in a position
to protect children he's a Class Act
this time yeah Greg he used that pardon
very wisely I agree completely Jesse I
have an advice to Democrats I wouldn't
get mad at Republicans for helping
parents it's not a good look what's next
you're going to go after puppies nuns
and babies they already do go after
babies uh and when you say that Junkin
helping parents is a political move God
I hope so because if a moral stance can
have a political impact thank God for
that uh that's been the problem with
this for forever we are watching right
now sexual exploitation of children and
they're using it through the this lie of
privacy it might be the most amoral acts
in slavery I mean they're actually
coming for kids again the game plan is
this create a false emergency they say
it's an attack on children privacy by
parents that is not real there is no
privacy cocoon around kids from their
parents this is a false assertion that
is a lot that is made to allow activists
and be very clear perverts perverts so
they can say this is our little secret
to a child please you don't have to tell
Mommy and Daddy we had this conversation
about your sexuality or your genitals in
the old days someone talk to your kid
like that he'd be in jail or he'd be
dead there is no privacy separation
between parents and children you should
fight to the death on that one and I
still love the fact that we said this a
long time ago the guy who's protecting
kids right now from delusional Democrats
or actually cowardly Democrats and
psychotic activists and the least
scientific medical theory in history
currently being implemented on children
his name is Young kin if that's not
proof that there is a higher power I
don't know what is Jessica why didn't
this D.A just say it's gone he had a
pardon just move on
well
her complaint is that there is an
ongoing legal investigation and he got
involved in it and she's also up for
re-election so the early voting window
opened and then suddenly Glenn youngkin
who's obviously been aware of this story
for multiple years decided that he
wanted to pardon the dad that's what she
said investigation
looking into his case is still ongoing
from what happened at the school board
meeting the kid is still under
investigation as well
he was convicted I thought it was still
open he should have been convicted
anyway that's what she's talking about
that there was that's the interference
that she's referring to but the larger
problem with this and Greg used the term
false emergency and this is a false
emergency but not in the way that Greg
is talking about because this is not
about trans kids and it's not about
gender neutral bathrooms this was a girl
who had been involved in a prior sexual
consensual relationship with this kid so
they had hooked up before he was wearing
a skirt that day but there is no
evidence that he has ever identified as
a woman
he was convicted
it was not that this was about being
attacked by a transgender person it was
a sexual assault is a responsible
he was convicted of do I ever say she
had sex with them before and therefore
he can have sex whatever he wants I have
never said that well never I no I didn't
I absolutely didn't
felt that they didn't do anything
because then he moved on to another
school and assaulted someone else
exactly but don't make this out about
that it's about transgender people
whether it's not can I respond because
you you directed it at me
um I have to tell you it is when you
start looking at what's happening in
women's prisons when there are men
saying that they are women I'm not
saying it's about transgender I'm
talking about I'm talking about men who
are saying they are women to take
advantage of women in private spaces we
can agree but and the bathroom policy
was not in place when the assault
happened well this is the only thing I
want to say so it's important to
remember that Scott Smith's case and the
issue and the images
that's what the Biden Administration
used in order to get that memo about
treating parents like domestic
terrorists exactly and they use his
video okay so that's also why it matters
and I would imagine Glenn Younkin who
said I'm going to make sure that I'm
focused on November of 2023 that's when
they have their elections in their state
that he is going to make sure that they
do the best job that they can on the
Republican side and the Virginia
Democrats a negative reaction to the
pardon that's very valuable for
Republicans going into this because they
just don't learn I mean when they when
Terry McAuliffe said that about parents
and children what happened Glenn young
can just sailed right in to a victory in
that off-year election all right thank
you Dana hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now